si maintenant près d'une année que les
lieux de spectacles et de cinéma sont
fermés les artistes ne peuvent plus
présenter leurs oeuvres au public ils
sont en détresse et veulent se faire
entendre venant de la culture s'est
introduit à l'intérieur de la
philharmonie de paris suite à un appel
de la fédération nationale des syndicats
du spectacle l'occasion de dénoncer la
défaite de la musique et de la diversité
et culturales notre journaliste charles
beaudry étaient sur place il leur a
demandé quelles sont leurs
revendications et côté les
professionnels alerte depuis de nombreux
mois maintenant
le gouvernement sur la situation
dramatique des acteurs du spectacle
vivant en france
visiblement nous ne parvenons pas à être
suffisamment entendue
donc nous avons décidé de monter le ton
comme il est de coutume de dire et
nous ne pouvons pas vraiment parler
d'une occupation par contre nous pouvons
parler de notre préoccupation est que
cette préoccupation va très certainement
se développer partout en france on dans
une déclaration du gouvernement
s'engageant à la prolongation des droits
des intermittents pour l'assurance
chômage
voilà une nouvelle nuit blanche et on
demande également 115 millions d'euros
pour financer des répétitions pour que
les personnes puissent retravailler en
l'absence de billetterie olala milles de
la culture se répondent dans les médias
en disant que c'est bon elle à la
situation en main elle souffre avec nous
mais en attendant les mesures concrètes
il n'y a rien eu d'obtenu depuis que l
est arrivé il ya des mesures pour
maintenir les emplois et les ce truc des
grosses structures mais ça ruisselle pas
si on peut se permettre cette
provocation